اهلا بكم هلا يا رئيس مجلس القياده
اليمنيه رشاد العليمي في برنامج مقابله
خاصه على شاشه العربيه قال ان ميليشيات
الحوثي رفضت تمديد الهدنه مشيرا الى ان
الهدنه كانت هشه ومليشيات الحوثي لم تلتزم
بدونها واضاف العليمي ان الحكومه اليمنيه
الشرعيه نفذ كما يخصها بالهدنه على عكس
الحوثي كما اوضح العليمي في مقابله في
المقابله بان ميليشيات الحوثي رفضت فتحه
طرق تعز كما استفادت بمليارات الريالات
اليمنيه من ميناء الحديده مشيرا الى
نمشيات الحوثي سرقت 45 مليار ريال يمني من
البنك المركزي في ما لم يحرك مجلس الامن
الدولي ساكنا جراء نهب الحوثي لاموال
الدوله كما اكد بان اليمن طالب المجتمع
الدوليه بتصنيف الحوثيين جماعه ارهابيه
لافتا الى ان
التغير في الموقف الامريكي تجاه
الميليشيات
الواقعه ان موضوع ال الهدنه همم نحن كما
تعرف عندما تشكل مجلس القياده الرئاسي
كانت الهدنه قائمه وقمنا بتجديد هذه
المدينه من طرف الحكومه الشرعيه
ولكن منذ اثنين اكتوبر الماضي همم
الميليشيات الحوثيه الارهابيه رفضت تمديد
الهدره
رغم كل الجهود اللي بدلت سواء من الاشقاء
همم في قياده التحالف والمملكه العربيه
السعوديه بالدرجه الرئيسيه
الامريكي والجهود ايضا العمانيه همم بدلت
في هذا الاتجاه ولكن للاسف همم رفضه
الحوثيه وحتى هذه اللحظه
وطبعا كانت الهدى هشه
من عدن ينضم الينا على العقيد الركن ياسر
صالح المحلل العسكري من لندن براء شيباني
باحت ومحلل سياسي وايضا من واشنطن احمد
الحنطي الباحث في الشان الامريكي اهلا بكم
جميعا
ليبدا اولا مع العقيد الركن ياسر صالح هذا
الاحباط الذي
كان قد
بدا واضحا وجليا في حديث
العليمي هل سيغير شيئا من
الواقع على الارض هل سيعيد همم ربما
التشكيلات العسكريه اليمنيه بما ينهي هذه
المساله اذا كانت الهدنه هشه
نعم حقيقه في البدايه شكرا لكم لضيفك
الكرام ااا ال ال الحديث لم يكن طابع
الاحباط موجود فيه بقدر ما كان همم
ظهر جليا لكل من تابع اللقاء بان الرئيس
رشاد العليمي ينحدر الى الى المدرسه
البرجماتيه الواقعيه اي بمعنى كان حديثه
حصيف جدا من بدايه اللقاء حتى نهايته ولم
يذهب الى
نرجسيه او الى اطلاق وعود او همم تغيير
الواقع الحقيقي او الوجه الحقيقي همم
الوضع في اليمن
عندما نتحدث عن الهدنه هو تحدث بصريح
العباره انه لا يوجد شريك سلام حقيقي اي
بمعنى انه همم محاولاته التي استمرت
بقياده المجلس القياده الرئاسي لمحاوله
ايجاد شريك حقيقه للسلام بالالتزام
بالهدنه رغم الخروجات الحوثيه رغم
التحديات الحوثيه رغم الانتهاكات الحوثيه
التي صلاه الى التدخل الى الى حرب مكتمله
الاركان في بعض الاحيان ولا يمكن ان
نسميها خرج ومع ذلك التزموا باعلى درجات
الصبر للعلى مسار السلام عبر طاوله الحوار
يقضي الى نتيجه حقيقيه لرفع معاناه الشعب
اليمني الذي تحدث من البدايه حتى النهايه
بانها هي ال- ال- ال- ال- السقف الذي تجري
كل القرارات التي تمت من قبل مجلس القيادي
الرئاسي هي مراعاه للوضع الانساني لابناء
الشعب اليمني ولرفع المعاناه الانسانيه عن
الشعب اليمني في تصوري الحديث عندما تحدث
عن التشكيلات العسكريه فعلا التشكيلات
العسكريه العسكريه قطعت شوط كبير في مجال
اعاده توحيد جهود كلها هذه القوه العسكريه
في مواجهه الميليشي الحوثيه التي تكون
الاداء الاخرى التي في حال فشلت السلام
عبر طاوله الحوار سيحقق السلام وهذا ما
كان واضحا في حديثه بانه لابد ان ينتهي
هذا الانقلاب وتنتهي الميليشيات انقلاب
الميليشي الحوثيه على سلطه الدوله وعوده
الدوله هو الهدف الرئيسي همم المجلس
القائد الرئاسي بلا شك من لندن براءه
الشيباني الباحثه والمحلل السياسي هل
الهدنه اليمنيه اليوم وبعد كلام همم
العليمي اصبحت بالفعل هي على المحك قد
تسقط هذه الهدنه وندخل في تغير جديد
للمشهد اليمني
نعم تحياتي لك همم فقط
تحيات تحياتي لك اخي عادل اام بالنسبه
لمشهد الهدنه هو مثل ما تحدث الرئيس
العليمي كلامه كان دقيق في هذه التوصيف
انه هش الاشكاليه في مجلس القياده الرئاسي
الاول الاشكال التي واجهها بشكل اساسي
ما هو الترتيبات في حال سقطت الهدنه ما هو
الترتيبات في حال حسدت جماعه الحوثي وبدات
هجما على المناطق الشرقيه او المحافظات
الجنوبيه او فتحت جبها في الساحل الغربي
ماذا ستكون رده فعل هل كل الوحدات
العسكريه والامنيه على اهبه الاستعداد
والجاهزيه في همم لتصدي
لهذا السيناريو ببساطه لان المجتمع الدولي
وتحديدا اذا اردت ان ان ان نوصفها
الموقف الاوروبي في هذه اللحظه مقترب كثير
من الاداره الامريكيه الحاليه هو متراجع
متردد لا يستطيع ان يتخذ قرار لانهم قرروا
منذ ترى طويله وكانت واضحه مع قدوم
الاداره الامريكيه الجديده انهم رفعوا
التصنيف بدون اي همم مقابل همم طلبوه من
جماعه الحوثي همم جماعه الحوثي لم تعد
تصنف كجماعه ارهابيه بالنسبه للاداره
الامريكيه
والمجتمع الاوروبي او الموقف الاوروبي رحب
بهذه الخطوه همم بمعنى اخر ان الموقف هم
كان بشكل واضح انهم سيتراجعوا همم الى
الوراء ثم سيكون هذا الموقف الذي هو لا
يستطيع انه يحسم همم ملفات بشكل نهائي مع
جماعه الحوثي ليس لديه اوراق قضاء ضغط او
بالاصح ويسلم اوراق الضغط التي يمتلكها
بدون اي بدون اي مقابل ثم عندما يفشل يذهب
بالضغط على الحكومه الشرعيه وهو ما اشار
اليه كذلك الرئيس عليم في في حديثه في هذه
في هذه المقابله انه كل ما يفشل في الضغط
على جماعه الحوثي يذهب هذا الضغط يذهب الى
همم الضغط على الحكومه الشرعيه بكون هناك
مؤسسه او هونها حكومه معترف بها دول طيب
الى الى واشنطن احمد الحنطي الباحث فيها
عشان الامريكي الولايات المتحده يعني
دورها ليس فقط وسيطا بل هي ايضا همم لها
دور كبير في
مسار السلام على الارض في اليمن ولكن بدا
ايضا احباط الرئيس العليمي من هذا الموقف
ماذا تنتظر واشنطن لتمارس دورها في هذا
الشان هو ضمان الهدنه على الاقل
طبعا عندما نتحدث عن سياسه اداره مايكل
بخصوص اليمن نحن نشرحها اول نزكيها يعني
اداره بيض لديها كثير منتخبات في هذا
الملف ولكن ما تنظر له امريكا هنا يعني
يخص اليمن امريكا لديها يعني مصلحتين
مباشره ومصلحتين غير مباشره لمصلحتين
مباشره
هاتين المصلحتين المتحققتين في ظل الوضع
الحالي فبالتالي هي لا تحتاج خطوات سريعه
او حاسمه لتغيير الكبير على الارض لتحقيق
هذه المصالح المصالح الغير مباشره
هيلاقتها مع السعوديه
مع ايران من الجهه الاخرى اداره انها
عندما يعني نقضت نقضت وعودتها لليسار يعني
نتذكر ايضا صرح قبل وبعد انتخابات 20 20
يوقف يعني سيوقف اي دعم امريكي للحرب في
اليمن ولكنه نقض هذا الوعد وحتى شاهدنا
مؤخرا يعني دخل في مواجهه معبر نيساندرس
في مجلس الشيوخ لما حاول برنيس اندرس يعني
تمرير قانون لمنع الحكومه الامريكيه من
تقديم اي شيء في هذه الحرب ف الاداره
الامريكيه ترى انها قدمت ما يريده التحالف
من خلال هذه الجهود وهذه يعني هذا الصراع
مواجهتها لهذا الجناح الداخلي عدم اعطاء
هذا الجناح ما يريد في المقابل هي لا تريد
ان تجعل اليمن ورق التفاوض في ايران هي
تعلم جيدا ان قرر الحوثي في طهران وليس في
صنعاء طيب لذلك ترى ان هي اذا دخلت اكثر
ربما تعطي ايران اوراق تفاوض اكثر طيب
سنعود لاستقبال الحديث ولكن همم دعونا
نذهب الى همم ما قاله ايضا الرئيس العليمي
في اللقاء الذي خاصه به العربيه يتحدث
رئيس مجلس القياده الرئاسي اليمني عن موقف
الاداره الامريكيه موضحا انها ترد على
الادله التي يتم تقديمها والتي تثبت تورط
غرام في اليمن بانها غير كافيه
ان نقنع المجتمع الدولي وفي المقدمه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ان هناك دعم ايران غير محدود لهذه الجماعه
وكان ونسلم ملفات بوثائق وادله متعدده
وكل ما كان ياتي يوافق امريكا الى صنعاء
كنا نسلم
وهو الملف رقم 20 اللي قد سلمناه همم
للاداره الامريكيه او العلاقه ايران
ودعمها للمتمردين فيصل
ولكن دائما يقولون ان الادله غير كافيه
قال نحن مقتنعين في البنتاجون وفي الشيعيه
ان هذه جماعه تتبع ايران ومدعومه من ايران
ولكن من يقنع البيت الابيض
باي ادله تريد الولايات المتحده حتى تقتنع
بان الحوثي يتبع وينفذ الاجنده الايرانيه
كما اشار همم يعني العليمي بانهم قدموا
ملفات عده ولكن الاداره الامريكيه لا تكتب
بهذه الادله لتدين
الاداره الامريكيه تعرف جيدا موقف الحوثي
وتبعيته وايران ولكنها لا تريد ان تضاع
اعتراف رسمي بهذا لانه
سيستنزل منها اتخاذ اجراءات اضافيه هي لا
تريد تاخذها في ظل التفاوض على الاتفاق
النووي تريد ان تجعل يعني ورقه اليمن شيء
اضافي اما بعد الاتفاق النووي او في
المراحل الاخيره منه لا تريد ان تجعله
الان لا تريد ان تقول لها ايران نعم لنقدم
لكم تنازل في اليمن قدموا لنا كذا او كذا
او كذا من التنازلات وتريد ان يكون هذا
الامر خارج المعادله حتى اللحظات الاخيره
لانها ترغب في تمرير اتفاق النووي يعني
ترغب بشده في هذا الامر ولكن بشروط جديده
تختلف عن 2015 وهذا الامر يبدو يبدو صعب
يعني يبدو بعيدا عن التحقيق لذلك هي لا
تريد ان تجعله اصعب على نفسها في الوقت
التي لا ترى يعني لا ترى امريكا ان لها
مصالح كبيره تحتاج لتحقيقها في اليمن في
الوقت الحالي طيب همم الى لندن براء
الشيباني الباحث هو المح السياسيه هل
تحولت القضيه اليمنيه لورقه ضغط كامله ما
بين طهران واشنطن وبالتالي ارتباطها
بالملف اليومي همم النووي عفوا للمساومه
همم
والجواب على سؤالك بشكل يعني محدد هو
روبرت مالي المبعوث الامريكي همم في
المفاوضات النوويه الايرانيه همم روبرت
مالي همم لديه ذهنيه يعتقد انه همم لا يجب
عليهم
مواجهه جماعه الحوثي بالمناسبه هو كتب ما
قال في همم نيويورك تايمز همم قبل تقريبا
سنتين يتحدث انه تقع معه قياده جماعه
الحوثي وانهم مستعدين للحوار مع الولايات
المتحده يعني كان اليمنيين غير معانيين
بهذا بهذه القضيه هم فقط المشكله انهم
الحوثيين
سيحاوره الولايات الولايات المتحده
الذهنيه التي داخل الاداره الحاليه يقودها
روبرت مالي وهو مقتنع انه يجب العوده الى
الاتفاقناوي الايراني وان المساله اليمنيه
الان مساله ثانويه يجب ان تحديدها وعدم
همم جعلها ورقه همم قد في فشل في فشل
الاتفاق بينما لا الدول العربيه هذا ملف
حيوي هذا ملف مهم جدا لانه مرتبط بالامن
الاقليمي للمنطقه مرتبط بمستقبل اليمنيين
بشكل بشكل كامل
همم هناك طرفين لا يتحدث نفس اللغه
المصالح والمختلفه الاهداف التي يريد ان
يصله لها مختلفه والاداره الحاليه
مقتنعه تماما انه يجب عليهم العوده الى
الاتفاق الراوي حتى في ظل همم المظاهرات
التي تحدث داخل ايران هناك اصوات مرتفعه
داخل الاداره الامريكيه تتحدث بشكل واضح
انه يجب العوده الى الاتفاقنا الايراني
وهذا ايضا هو نفس المقارنه الاوروبيه هم
مقتربين جدا جدا لديهم نفس المقاربه فيما
يتعلق بهذا الملف طيب العقيد الركن ياسر
صالح المحلل العسكري يعني دائره التشابك
توسعت وحتى ضاعت في ملفاتها القضيه
اليمنيه كاولويه لكن كما ذكر ضيفي من
واشنطن احمد الحنطي امم ما يهم هو امن
الملاح هل الولايات المتحده اليوم ترى بان
الوضع لا يستوجب التدخل لتغييره وبالتالي
يبقى كما هو عليه طالما لا شيء خطر في امن
الملاحه الاقليميه
نعم حقيقه ضيفه كان دقيق في توصيفه ولكن
همم اريد ان اؤكد ان ما اتحدث به فخامه
الرئيس همم من وس- من وسائل الاقناع
للاداره الامريكيه كان يتحدث عن الفتره ما
بين عام 2000 وما بين عام 2010 تحديدا
عندما سلم الملف وهو نائم رئيس الوزراء
لشؤون الدفاع والامن همم في تصور المرحله
تطورت كثيرا ولكن الاداره الامريكيه ما
زالت تمارس نفس الادوات ونفس ال- اا
الذهنيه في التعامل مع الميليشيا الحوثيه
لكن همم خلال اشهر الهدنه همم اختلف
المشهد تماما واذا اصرت الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ان تتعامل بنفس التماهي او
اللين السياسي ما اطلق عليه في وسائل
الاعلام الامريكيه سياسه لين السياسي
للاداره الامريكيه الجديده في اتجاه
الميليشي الحوثيه فلا شك ان كل المصالح
الحيويه في همم المياه الاقليميه اليمنيه
وفي مضيق باب المندب تحديدا هي في حاله
خطر حقيقي ما الذي تغير حتى يجعلني اطلق
مثل هذا الجرار حقيقه هي الدراسه حقيقيه
عندما نتحدث عن وسائل الردع او وسائل ال-
ال- ال- ال- ال- الترسانه همم التي دخلت
الى منظومه العمل العسكري للمليشيا
الحوثيه خلال الاشهر الماضيه ترى سنه تؤكد
بان الهدف الرئيسي هو المياه الاقليميه
والملاحه الدوليه في البحر الاحمر الدليل
على ذلك اشياء كثيره الدليل الاول ان رئيس
هيئه اركان القوات البحريه في الحرس
الثوري الايراني تحدث في بدايه العام بان
22 سيكون عام البحريه الايرانيه في البحر
الاحمر اثنين اصول الاسلحه ال- ال-
المتخصصه للقتال البحر عندما نتحدث عن
العرض العسكري الذي اقيم في الحديده
واربع منظومات همم صواريخ موجهه ارض بحر
واربعه صواريخ مختلفه ايضا بعيده المدى
ارض بحر اذا نحن نتحدث عن تهديد حقيقي
اضافه الى اطلاق التصريحات الميليشيا
الحوثييه
ان المعركه البحريه ستكون قاسيه كان اخرها
منذ حوالي شهر رئيس هيئه منتحل رئيس هيئه
الاستخبارات الحوثيه تحدث بان لا يجب ان
نركن الى الهدنه وان المعركه البحريه
ستكون همم قاسيه اضافه الى ذلك حديث رئيس
قائد الحرس الثوري منذ اسبوعين باننا نحن
خطرون وعليكم الحذر وهو يوجه في هذا
الكلام في سياقه عندما تحدث عن الاعداء
الخارجيين وعن المصالح الحيويه الممتده في
نطاق جغرافيه ايران او في نطاق اذرع ايران
وهو ما تحدث ايضا ما يوضح لنا استراتيجيه
هذا الاداره الجديده الايرانيه طيب لا
يوجد في في ابجديات او في ادبيات الامن
القومي الايراني
واضحه ولكن نستطيع ان نستشفها من خطاب
رئيس الجمهوريه الايرانيه عندما تحدث بان
همم ادواته في المنطقه هي ال- ال- الهدف
الاول الذي يجب ان يحافظ عليه اضافه الى
المصدات التي يجب ان تواجه ايران فيها اي
تهديدات خارجيه وهو تحدث عن اذرعه
الموجوده طيب اذا ايضا ساذهب الى مقطع اخر
مما تحدث به الرئيس العليمي خلال هذه
المقابله الخاصه لقناه العربيه اشار رشاد
العليمي رئيس مجلس القياده الرئاسي اليمني
الى انه اختار المانيا لزيارتها كاول دوله
اجنبيه لانهم يدركون تاثير الموقف
الالمانيه على الحوثيين الذين يراهنون
عليهم حتى ان بعض عناصر الحوثي موجوده هنا
اول زياره كان لي مثلا انا لدوله اجنبيه
خارج اطار المنطقه العربيه كان زياره
لالمانيا
لانه ندرك ان الموقف الالماني موقف مهم
وداخل الاتحاد الاوروبي
والحوثيين كانوا يراهنوا كثيرا على على
المواقف الالمانيه
وكان لهم تواجد لعناصرهم همم
الناعمه اللي مسميها اللي تتواجد في
اوروبا وفي امريكا وفي هذه المناطق
وحصل تغير في الموقع الاوروبي
طيب اعود الى ضيوف السيد احمد الحنطي يعني
ارجو الاختصار لانه عندي محور ثانيه حابب
نناقشه ولكن بالموازات مع واشنطن هناك
الموقف الاوروبي ايضا هذا الموقف ليس كما
يعجب القياده اليمنيه ما مر ذلك
من
البدايه اليمن
يعني اكثر ليونه سواء كانت المانيا او حتى
بريطانيا
على على مسار الحرب على المسار الشرعيه
يعني في ما يخص منها الحديده وغير ذلك لا
استطيع ان الحديث عن اسباب ذلك طيب اذا
اذا همم السيد براء الشيبان الباحث هو
المحلل السياسي من لندن الموقف الاوروبي
ايضا كان ليس على قدر ما يود الرئيس
اليمني
نعم انا اريد حتى اعطيك مثال بسيط في
بدايه الحرب كانت لي زياره الى
المانيا واذكر بشكل واضح كانت هناك مظاهره
يقودها يقوده حوثيين يهتفوا بشكل واضح
بشعارهم الذي هو فيها الموت الامريكي
والموت كل هذه الشعارات التي فيها حتى
فيها اشعارات اشاره عنصريه ويهتفوها
ويفتحوها على الملا يعني ليس هناك حتى قلق
او تخوف منهم يظهروا يظهروا هويتهم الى
العالم الان قدر الملف اليمني للاسف انه
ابتدات الحرب في نفس الشهر تقريبا الذي
حصل فيها التوقيع على الاتفاق النووي
الايراني كان الاتحاد الاوروبي هو حجر
زاويه وتحديدا المانيه كانت تحول الكثير
على هذا على هذا على هذا الاتفاق منذ ذلك
ال همم التاريخ همم الاتحاد الاوروبي
يعتقد ان الملف اليمني ملف يثقل همم
تقاربهم مع مع ايران في المنطقه
ويعرقل كثير همم المسار التفاوضى في ما
يخص الاتفاق همم اتفاق النووي النووي
الايراني» ولذلك كانوا يمارسوا ضغط غير
مسبوق على دول الخليج بشكل اساسي ثم على
الحكومه الشرعيه انها تقدم تنازلات وبعض
الاحيان تكون هذه التنازلات حتى ولو
بالمتجانه المهم ان لا تكون هناك اي ملفات
وهذه وهذه انا اعتقد ال- ال- حجر الزاويه
في هذا الملف بالكامل
المقاربه الاوروبيه تعتمد على مصلحتها همم
مصلحتها في في في في في هذه المرحله وبعد
ذلك ياتي ونويات اليمنيين مستقبل اليمنيين
ماذا يخص امن المنطقه وهذه اعتقد
المانيا او الاوروبيين في المقام الاول
اللي اذهب عن الاموال التي نتحدث عنها
وتحدث عنها الرئيس اليمني عن هذه الاموال
التي نهبها الحوثيون قال رشاد العليمي
رئيس مجلس القياده الرئاسي اليمني لقناه
العربيه ان جماعه الحوثي نهبت ما يقارب ال
45 مليار ريال يمني من البنك المركزي في
الحديده على الرغم من ان هذه الاموال كانت
مخصصه لصرف رواتب المناطق التي يسيطرون
عليها وفق اتفاقيه سوكو
الارهابيه اكثر من 45 مليار ريال من البنك
المركزي في الحديده وكان وفقا الاتفاقيه
السكر كانت مخصصه
لمرتبات الموظفين في مناطق سيطره
الميليشيات الارهابيه الكويتيه ورقم ذلك
انه يبات هذه الميليشيات ولم يحرك ساكنه
من المجلس الامن ولا حتى بيدانا لهذه
المبالغ الماليه التي نهبها الحوثيون من
البنك المركزي فرع الحديده همم ويسخروها
لي خدمه مجهولين الحربي
الى عدن هذه المره العقيده الركن ياسر
صالح المحلل العسكري يعني هذا ما استمعنا
اليه حتى ان ال ال المطلوب من الرئاسه
اليمنيه ان تدفع لكل اليمنيين سواء في
المناطق التي يسيطر عليها الحوثيون وحتى
المناطق
المحرره من من ايديهم ولكن اليس ذلك عبء
انا ايضا على همم القياده اليمنيه وعلى
هذا المجلس
كبير ولكن المجلس منذ اول يوم تاسيسه اصر
على هذه النقطه وهذا واجب تاريخي همم
لكن الحقيقه ما اتحدث به فخامه الرئيس في
هذه النقطه تحديدا عن المبلغ 45 مليار هذا
ما كان مشمولا في اتفاقيه استقال الذي
يورد الى الى بنك الحديده ولكن ماذا عن
اكثر من 200 مليار التي جنتها الميليشي
الحوتيه او تحصلتها من ميناء الحديده
عبرناقلات النفطه التي سمح المجلس القيادي
الرئاسي بدخولها اثناء فتره الهدنه وما
زالت مستمر الى يومنا هذا من اجل ان تغطي
رواتب موظفيه الدوله على كشوفات ما قبل
عام 2014 تحديدا الميليش يتصرف في هذا
تريد ان همم تلغي هذه المبالغ باكملها وان
تدفع الحكومه من لديها بالكشوفات الموجوده
لديها اي بمعنى مليشياتها التي اوجدتها ما
بعد عام 2014 ومن يقاتلون معها وما مدونه
السلوك الوظيفي التي اشترطت الولاء لهذه
الجماعه والاشتراك في القتال مع هذه
الجماعه الا تاكيد لمن هم المستحقين اي
بمعنى كل الموظفين او عمال المؤسسات
الدوله التي لا يخضعون للشيخ الحوثيه
ويلدونون بالولاء المطلق ويقاتلون مع
الجماعه الحوثيه غير مستحقين لهذه الرواتب
وهذه هي المعضله الحقيقيه المليشه الحوثيه
هي من تمصلت من هذا الامر تحديدا وليس
المجلس القيادي الرئاسي المجلس القيادي
الرئاسي تتحدث مع المجتمع الدولي انه في
حاله حجز ميناء الحديده وموارد الدوله
التي موجوده لدى المليشي الحوثيه من ضرائب
ومن جمارك ومن مؤسسه صالات التي ارادتها
تتجاوز 300 مليار سنويا بان الحكومه
الشرعيه مستعده ان تغطي العجز ولكن مليشيا
الحوثييه تريد ان تتجاوز ذلك بان يكون كل
شيء عبئا على الدوله همم همم اضافه الى
ذلك ان سمحتني بالعوده الى همم الموضوع
الالماني هنالك المصالح المتقاطعه
المشتركه حقيقه مع ايران هو ما كان يؤثر
على الموقف الالماني اضافه الى ذلك بعد
خروج بريطانيا من الاتحاد الاوروبي اصبحت
فرنسا والمانيا هي محور القرار في الاتحاد
الاوروبي وشاهدنا هذا ال- ال- العكس سلبا
على موقف الاتحاد الاوروبي من الجماعه
الحوثيه ولا طالما كانت المانيا هي الملاذ
الامن للجماعه الحوثيه بدليل ان يحيى بدر
الدين الحوثي شقيقه عبد الملك الحوثي
الاكبر كان متواجدا في المانيا لدى سنوات
طويله اي منذ عام 2004 لذلك همم اليوم يجب
ان يتغير هذا الموقف وفقا لمعطيات حقيقيا
مستنده على المصلحه اليمنيه العليا والشعب
اليمني وليس على المصالح الانيه خصوصا بان
كل المصالح الحيويه الموجوده في المنطقه
باتت مهدده تهديد مباشر باسلحه همم
الايرانيين التي زودوا بها الحوثيه خلال
الفتره الاخيره وهو ما يريد ان يصبح
بموجبها الرجم الصعب في معادله الامن
والسلم الدوليين خصوصا على مستوى المنطقه
او على مستوى الملاحه الدوليه طيب العقيده
الركن ياسر صالح المحلل العسكري من عدا
شكرا جزيلا لك من واشنطن احمد الحنطي
الباحث في الشان الامريكيه شكر موصول لك
وكذلك من لندن براءه شيبان الباحث والمحلل
السياسي شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]